THE PAST.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST MARK STEYN, WHO
ELSE JOINS US TONIGHT?
MARK, HOW IS THE SHAPE OF
YOUR DEMOCRACY TONIGHT?
>> WELL, SOMETIMES IT IS
SHAPED LIKE A SAUSAGE AND
EGG McMUFFIN AND OTHER
TIMES IT’S SHAPED LIKE
SCARLETT JOHANSSON IN THAT
CUTE LITTLE OUTFIT SHE WEARS
IN THE AVENGERS.
UNLESS IT’S ONE OF THOSE
TWO, IT DOESN’T REALLY --
WHEN I HEAR THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE, THEY DON’T SEEM
EXERCISED ABOUT ITS SHAPE
GENERALLY UNLESS IT’S LIKE
THE EGG AND SAUSAGE McIF
YOUMCMUFFIN.
BY THE WAY HAS THE APPLAUSE
DIED DOWN YET FOR MAYOR
PETE’S LINE ABOUT NEEDING TO
BUILD A FUTURE THAT IS
BETTER THAN THE PAST?
IS IT STILL RINGING IN OUR
EARS?
I THINK I HEARD THE FAKE
SOUND OF SOMEONE GOING WOO
ON TAPE AT AN EPISODE OF I
LOVE LUCY IN 1956 AS THEY
MANAGED TO EDIT ONTO THE END
OF MAYOR PETE’S SPEECH THERE
IT’S FANTASTICALLY
IMPRESSIVE.
>> Tucker: I SHOULD SAY FOR
THE AUDIENCE WATCHING AT
HOME YOU NEVER HAVE THE
QUESTIONS AHEAD OF TIME.
THAT’S WHY IT’S FUN TO HAVE
THIS PERSON ON TELEVISION.
LET ME JUST ASK YOU, DO YOU
THINK THE PEOPLE AROUND PETE
BUTTIGIEG, HE JUST HIRED A
NEW ADVISOR FROM GOLDMAN
SACHS.
DO YOU THINK THEY ARE CLEVER
ENOUGH TO CONVINCE THE
COUNTRY THAT THIS IS A REAL
CANDIDATE AND NOT SOME KIND
OF CORPORATE HOLOGRAM?
>> WELL, I THINK CORPORATE
HOLOGRAM IS RIGHT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANY
CANDIDATE WHO IS SO POLL
TESTED AND FOCUS GROUP AS
THIS ONE.
IT’S INTERESTING TO ME THAT
THE -- THIS IS THE FIRST
MILLENNIAL TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AND ACCORDING TO
HOW YOU SLICE IT HE MAY OR
MAY NOT HAVE WON THE IOWA
CAUCUS.
AND HE IS IN WITH A SPORTING
CHANCE OF DOING THE SAME IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
YET, IT’S ACTUALLY WITH
YOUNGER VOTERS, HE IS
INCREDIBLY UNPOPULAR.
AND INTERESTINGLY, TO ME,
BECAUSE EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT
IDENTITY POLITICS.
THIS GUY OHT TO BE ROMPING
HOME ON THAT FRONT BECAUSE
AS WE KNOW HE IS GAY.
AND HIS HUSBAND WOULD BE THE
FIRST FIRST GENTLEMAN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THE YOUNGER, THE MILLENNIALS
AND GENERATION Z. DON’T LIKE
HIM BECAUSE IN SHORTHAND, I
GUESS, HE IS A GAY SQUARE.
HE MIGHT AS WELL BE JOE
BIDEN ZIP IT UP INTO SOME
KIND OF YOUTHFUL BODY SUIT.
AND IT’S INTERESTING TO ME
THAT YOUNG VOTERS ARE NOT --
THE GAY THING DOESN’T TRUMP
FOR THEM THE FACT THAT HE IS
NOT RADICAL ENOUGH ON THE
POLICY.
THAT’S ACTUALLY QUITE
INTERESTING ON HOW IDENTITY
POLITICS DOESN’T EVEN PLAY
WITH THE MILLENNIAL CROWD.
>> Tucker: NO.
NOBODY LIKES IT.
NOBODY LIKES WOKENESS.
11 PEOPLE ON TWITTER ALL OF
THEM LIVE IN BROOKLYN AND
HOLDING THE COUNTRY HOSTAGE
AND EVERYBODY SECRETLY HATES
THEM.
IF HE DOES, IN THE END, WIN
THE NEW HAMPSHIRE PRIMARY
AND BERNIE JUST KIND OF
DISAPPEARS OR ALL THE VOTES
ARE, YOU KNOW, STOLEN AND
THEN RETURNED, ARE PEOPLE
GOING TO BUY THIS?
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
I MEAN, I THINK HE RUNS INTO
SOME PRETTY SEVERE PROBLEMS
ONCE HE GETS TO SOUTH
CAROLINA.
WHEN THE INTERNAL
CONTRADICTIONS OF THE
RAINBOW COALITION AS MARX
MIGHT HAVE PUT IT WILL COME
INTO PLAY VERY
INTERESTINGLY.
THAT’S WHY YOU GET THIS
NUTTY TALK ABOUT BLOOMBERG
AND MAYBE EVEN DRAFTING MITT
ROMNEY NOW HE IS THE HOLIEST
PERSON ON THE PLANET.
SO THEY ARE STILL LOOKING
FOR THEIR DREAM CANDIDATE
AND THIS GUY ISN’T REALLY
CUTTING IT FOR THEM.